de lujo empezamos una nueva sección
estamos en la sección 4 del examen 3 y
bueno esta es la primera parte porque
voy a hacer el primer problema que está
en la página 530 así que vamos a
resolver el primer problema y dice ese
máster es igual a 3s master esto es
igual a 3 perfecto y después nos
preguntan cuánto valen s más de menos 6
s más de menos 6 esencialmente lo que yo
quiero saber es esto qué bueno realmente
la única dificultad es recordar que ese
master vale 3 en esta parte de arriba
nos dice que ese más te vale 3 y aquí
tengo ese máster que vale 3 lo que
realmente nos están pidiendo es saber
cuándo es 3 menos 6 y bueno tres menos
seis es menos 3
así que realmente en este problema
estaba muy sencillo es el inciso am
recuerda que en un principio vienen los
problemas sencillos mientras que después
todo se pone un poco más interesante así
que vamos a probar nos vamos a ver el
problema número dos el problema número
dos y tiene un cubo así que déjame ver
si me sale mi cubo dibujemos por aquí un
cubo tengo algo así después tengo una
recta por acá
más o menos así tengo otra recta por acá
algo más o menos
así tengo otra vuelta por acá que une
estos 2 algo más o menos así me sobre
este espacio si quiere que me borrarlo
borremos esta parte de aquí
ok borrar bien y después tengo que hacer
una parte muy parecida a ésta
necesitamos una buena explicación algo
más o menos como por aquí y después este
sube para acá bien ya casi tengo un cubo
porque me falta la parte de atrás este
baja este baja y después aquí tengo
líneas punteadas tengo a este este va
subiendo como por acá llegamos a este
punto este punto sube sube sube sube
como por acá y después esto se va para
acá muy bien aquí térmico y además tengo
algunas letras déjame cambiar de color
para ponerte estas letras este es el
punto pm este es el punto en este es el
punto cu éste el de atrás es el punto y
este es el punto d
este es el punto sem y por último este
es el punto d y me preguntan en el cubo
de la figura siguiente todos los
tienen la misma distancia tanto a p
tanto apple como aquí excepto y me ponen
todos los incisos excepto a excepto b
excepto c excepto de o excepto en cuál
de estos puntos no tiene la misma
distancia al punto pm que al punto y así
que vamos a ver si yo empiezo con el
punto a este punto am está a una arista
del punto p está a esta arista del punto
pm y también está a una arista del punto
com
por lo tanto amp tiene la misma
distancia del punto p que al punto que
por lo tanto esto no es mi respuesta
correcta vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa
con ver ven está a dos aristas del punto
p está a esta ya está está a estas dos
aristas del punto p pero por otra parte
también está a dos aristas del punto que
fíjate bien si yo me voy por aquí
y después bajo por acá
entonces llegó al punto cu con las
mismas dos aristas por lo tanto de esta
a la misma distancia de p que de cv e
inclusive podríamos llegar de aquí para
acá y de ahí para acá y al final es la
misma distancia entonces ve no es mi
solución porque recuerda que yo estoy
buscando un punto que cumpla que no
tenga la misma distancia ap que aquí así
que vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con
cm
se está aquí y se está a una arista de
cvm a esta arista de cv mientras que de
p
está muy lejos está a una arista de p a
otra lista de p
puedo bajar por acá y después a otra
arista por dp está hasta acá de hecho
ésta hasta el otro extremo de p es decir
que la distancia que hay desde aquí es
mucho más corta que la distancia que hay
de ap es recorrer todo esto es recorrer
estas tres aristas por lo tanto mi
respuesta es
mi respuesta sé que ese es decir el
sistema ya está tengo aquí la respuesta
del problema número 2 y bueno pues vamos
a hacer el siguiente problema el
problema número 13 borremos la pantalla
y ahora sí
pensemos en el problema número 3 el
problema número 3 y un muchacho en este
problema hay muchas cosas que dibujar
déjame ver qué dice el problema a ver si
es necesario dibujar todo esto tal vez
se pueda resolver sin necesitar tantos
dibujos la gráfica de barras siguiente
muestra los fraudes cometidos en
internet cuál de las siguientes gráficas
de pastel representa exactamente la
misma gráfica de líneas creo que no está
tan difícil este problema y no hay de
otra tenemos que hacer estas gráficas
así que vamos a hacer estas gráficas amd
voy a dibujar una línea como por aquí
voy a hacer una gráfica de pastel voy a
utilizar el color magenta el color
magenta y me dicen páginas web o sitios
web o páginas de internet páginas
páginas
web web el porcentaje de que se cometa
un fraude en una página web es del 78
por ciento así que déjame ponerte aquí
un 78%
supongamos que este es el 78% 78% y voy
a colgar todo esto de aquí todo esto
todo esto segundo dato que me dan correo
electrónico o email
no voy a poner aquí correo
electrónico electrónico nico bueno el
correo electrónico tiene un porcentaje
de fraude del 18 por ciento así que
vamos a hacer igual una pequeña barra
por aquí obras del 18 como por aquí y
este es el 18 por ciento o no espera
estoy equivocando me de herramienta este
es el 18 por ciento
este es el 78 por ciento am y voy a
colorear todo esto es correo electrónico
y después me dicen que el fraude también
se comete en los grupos de noticias así
que vamos a ponerlo aquí los grupos
grupos de noticias no ti
si has y dice que los grupos de noticias
tengo un porcentaje del 2 por ciento de
que se cometió un fraude así que tengo
un porcentaje muy pero muy pero muy
pequeño este es mi 2 por ciento de que
se cometa un fraude en un grupo de
noticias y bueno por último tengo otros
así que déjenme tomar un color para
otros
voy a suponer este color
a otros u otros y en otros ésta es
bastante que es también un 2% así que
déjenme poner aquí un 2% para otros
algo más o menos así éste también es el
2% y lo tengo más o menos así bueno esto
mismo lo voy a tener que representar en
una gráfica de pastel esencialmente eso
es lo que nos piden tomarnos una gráfica
de pastel así que vamos a trabajar en
ella voy a hacer un círculo como por
aquí más o menos como éste y vamos a
trazar cada uno de los datos que me dan
páginas web páginas web tiene un 78 por
ciento y es de color magenta así que 78
por ciento y déjame tomar este 78 por
ciento y entonces nosotros lo pasamos
aquí en nuestra gráfica de pastel
yo tendría un punto y tengo esta recta y
si hablo del 78% eso está muy cercano al
y el 75% de un pastel o de algo es lo
mismo que tres cuartas partes es decir
que si a esto lo dividimos en tres
cuartas partes quedaría pasando las tres
cuartas partes es decir me quedaría algo
como por aquí este sería mi 78% voy a
suponer algo como por aquí perfecto y
abraham vamos a tomarnos esta
herramienta para que tengamos el mismo
color este es mi 78% de las páginas web
así que vamos a ponerlo aquí de las
páginas web ok ahora por otra parte
tengo en correo electrónico un
porcentaje de 18% así que si me tomo un
18%
utilizando la misma lógica 18% es menor
que 25% que es un cuarto de esta
circunferencia así que me va a quedar
algo muy parecido
y esto me va a quedar algo como por aquí
bien este va a ser mi correo electrónico
y de igual manera me voy a tomar esta
herramienta y lo voy a colorear perfecto
aquí tengo el correo electrónico el i
el perfecto ahora tengo grupos de
noticias y otros con un 2% así que lo
que sobra lo voy a dividir a la mitad
para acabar esta gráfica de pastel a
esto lo voy a dividir a la mitad y bueno
en un principio aquí tengo grupos de
noticias que es esta parte de aquí y
también tengo otros que es esta parte de
aquí y ya está con esto tengo el final
de mi gráfica de pastel y es momento de
fijarnos en los incisos porque de hecho
los únicos incisos que tienen que las
páginas web cobran más del 75 por ciento
de este pastel es decir más las tres
cuartas partes de este pastel son el
inciso sem y el inciso de ahora la
diferencia entre el inciso c y el inciso
tema es que se no tienen nada para otros
es decir que todo esto está coloreado
del grupo de noticias se les olvidó
poner otros o no lo tomaron importante
mientras que si es importante por lo
tanto la respuesta correcta
es el inciso de la cual tenemos una
gráfica de pastel muy parecida a ésta
con otros colores pero esa es la
respuesta el inciso de así que ya tengo
este problema no estaba tan complicado
tal vez un poco laborioso pero bueno es
hora de borrar todo esto y voy a
resolver el siguiente problema el
problema número 4 el problema número 4 y
nos dice
el numerador de una cierta fracción es 5
unidades menor que el denominador así
que voy a suponer que el denominador de
esta fracción se llama x y bueno el
numerador es 5 unidades menor que el
denominador es decir que si el
denominador vale x aquí arriba tenemos x
menos 55 unidades menos que el
denominador muy bien y dice que la
fracción esta fracción es igual a tres
cuartos lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale el denominador es decir cuánto vale
x y esencialmente tengo aquí una
ecuación que creo que es muy sencilla de
resolver lo único que hay que hacer es
pasar este multiplicando para acá está
multiplicando para acá y me quedaría que
4 que multiplica a x menos 5 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3x
ahora puedo distribuir este 4 por éste y
por este y me va a quedar que 4 x menos
20 esto es igual a 3x y ahora voy a
restar 3x de ambos lados de la ecuación
3x este lado 3x de este lado y también
voy a sumar 20 de ambos lados de la
ecuación voy a sumar 20 aquí me voy a
sumar 20 acá de tal manera que del lado
izquierdo este y este se van y me queda
4 x menos 3 x lo cual es x y del lado
derecho me va a quedar que este y este
se va y solamente me queda 20 x vale 20
que es justo lo que quería el
denominador vale 2010 el inciso de
perfecto el insisto tema y éste estuvo
muy fácil así que vamos a hacer un
último problema vamos a hacer el
problema número 5
y el problema número 5 tienen una
gráfica así que espero que me dé tiempo
de hacer esta gráfica muestra tan
difícil tengo dos ejes a un eje por aquí
este es mi hijo james y por acá tengo a
mi eje de las x a más o menos así y
bueno en x voy de camps a 6 k aquí tengo
cam aquí tengo 2 k por acá tengo 3 k por
acá tengo cuatro acá y por acá tengo 5
cam y para finalizar tengo 66 acá cada
dos cada tres cada cuatro cada cinco
casas scan creo que tú ves el punto por
acá y aquí arriba tengo del 1 al 6 tengo
6 y después tengo un triángulo y aquí
viene lo bueno tengo que dibujar con
mucha calma a este triángulo este
triángulo está en el 22 empieza justo
como por aquí después se va hasta el 5
acá es decir me voy hasta acá
más o menos por aquí tengo la base y
después sube hasta 6 pasando por el
punto medio si yo divido este esté justo
como por a caster punto medium entonces
hasta acá llegó con 6 y como por aquí
aquí baja este triángulo para acá y
también baja este otro triángulo para
acá más o menos tengo este triángulo el
cual va de 2 k subiendo hasta por acá
hasta llegar al 2 y después del 5 cam va
subiendo por acá hasta llegar al 2 y
después sube hasta el valor de 6 que
está justo en el punto medio de estos
dos valores y me dicen en la gráfica
siguiente la escala en el eje de las x
es distinta esta escala es distinta a la
escala en el eje de las 10
después me dicen si el triángulo a veces
tiene como área 18 unidades cuadradas el
área del triángulo abc este es el
triángulo a veces déjame ponerlo
d
perfecto el área del triángulo abc el
área es igual a 18 unidades cuadradas
este dato es muy importante y después me
preguntan cuál es el valor de cam
cuánto vale acá yo lo que quiero saber
es el valor de acá
ahora bien recordemos que el área de un
triángulo la obtenemos multiplicando la
base por la altura entre 2 o dicho de
otra manera es un medio la
multiplicación de la base por la altura
el área es igual a un medio de la base
pero la base va de 5k a 2k
cuánto hay de 5 cada 2 camps esto es lo
mismo que tres veces que me moví una vez
que dos veces cada tres veces cam
mientras que de altura cuánto tiene este
triángulo pues vamos de 2 a 6 de 2 a 6
subimos 4 unidades
entonces esto x
este por 4 perfecto y yo sé por otra
parte que el área es exactamente lo
mismo que 18 unidades esto es lo mismo
que 18 unidades y de aquí ya casi
obtengo la solución de este problema yo
lo que necesito saber es el valor de
campo bueno vamos a dividir 4 entre 24
entre 2 es dos a dos por tres es 6 es
decir que seis veces acá esto es igual a
18 y si yo divido entre 6 esta parte y
en 36 esta parte
ahora si obtengo que el valor de camps
es igual a 18 entre 6 lo cual es 3
perfecto acá igual a 3 y es el inciso y
la respuesta de este problema es el
inciso en que es 3 perfecto no tengo más
tiempo en este vídeo así que le seguimos
en el siguiente vídeo no te lo pierdas